are you tired of hearing about Logan
Paul that's great
me too but before we move on to the next
drama that will inevitably happen and
forget about everything that I went down
we need to consider I forgot damn
it damn it damn it keep forgetting I
said the back oh well you gotta give the
pole brother some props you know they
they got a good ball game going on you
know one person does something and all
the sudden you you completely forgotten
what how bad the other one was and then
just back and forth as you can tell
Logan Paul is in deep pain after this
incident he's he's suffering immensely
clearly his audience put put their feet
down and said no Logan you stepped over
the line a lot of people are pointing
out with the suicide forest video that
it was just a mistake
okay everyone makes mistake you make
mistake - Felix that is true I have I'm
guilty but people also started watching
Logan's older videos and notice a
continuous pattern go eyes are gonna
know I'm a little sick my voice is kind
of gone Oh God watch it tomato did you
start tomato on our wall that's
hilarious delivery guys the most
entertaining exhilarating incredible
content please throw another tomato in
the walkers that was hilarious
being sick gonna be selfish no Logan
Paul masse and Logan Paul that cops last
shot get your own sick mass and prevent
the bubonic plague from spreading in
your town just this one just for a
display oh okay that's my bad how old is
he
so while in Japan Logan Paul clearly
knew about the Japanese culture they
really value respect above anything I
just got to be careful to not like
disrespect their culture as well getting
Japan is on
I know it's true so I got to take my
chach levels and bring them down I
didn't edit that to make him look bad he
he added this is where you throw coins
into the well we make a wish and they
come true or even a wish for I wish for
health happiness and hello you
know when you're in a church or mosque
or Buddhist temple there's genuinely the
approach that you keep it down a notch
sure you're a bit more quiet like I'm
not religious or anything like that but
even then I I'm still you know you need
to show a certain amount of respect and
you're at a Buddhist temple just
throwing in money in the thing like
whatever it's so dumb you do know some
of the authorities weren't happy about
them acting this way and their guide is
the one that apologizes he's the one
that has to step on put me like I'm
sorry for this person all right guys
we're gonna see you back because you're
at a Buddhist temple it might be a
tourist attraction and a lot of people
there as someone who really loves Japan
and love visiting there I'm always
really on guard whenever I'm there I
don't want to be that person that Logan
Paul and his friends are I don't want to
be it's not attractive it's not someone
you want to be you know how it is in
Japan they're all about the respect
we're gonna be respectful for a little
bit I know it's new but we got to do
with sometimes literally the next the
next cut he's not sick I get that he's
sick and then that's a problem but then
we're them in Japan it's a big
deal to be spreading germs like they
have the masks not not to protect
themself from other people being sick
they haven't if you're sick do not
made it to other people it's another
respectful thing that if you are sick
you don't spread that disease around
it's considered really rude to be
sneezing and coughing out in public as
well and it's simple things that you
could have looked up you've been to
Japan twice you should know this and if
you think I'm just nitpicking at this
point don't worry it gets worse oh my
god be more on Logan's slogan his whole
identity with his Brandis BMF this is
merch that's what he sells that that's
what he acts like but you're just being
annoying you're just being
annoying this is sort of attitude that
he's emitting towards his fans like be
like me being be an idiot this
is okay you know you've gotta be edgy
you gotta do stuff that no one else does
but it's like I get that I get that not
everyone should be the same but
goddamnit I hope no one else is like you
if you want to see the fish at the fish
market in Japan don't party with
thoughts the night before yeah I'm also
not giving up hope you know that's what
I'm talking about so look and Paul goes
to the fish market which is very famous
and it's already sort of shutting down
because they don't want tours in there
because they're being too it's being too
much of them it's becoming too much of a
tourist attraction it's really just
people working there it's a fish market
after all and then you have Logan Paul
of course furthering that even more by
just buying fish
to walk around in public with like you
have people literally scarfing at him
but can you imagine how many of those
there that is edited out and of course
what a maverick I can't believe he just
did that that is let MP Wow I wish I was
that brave to do that cuz men
that's pretty energy I just want to say
one thing though Japanese people are so
nice
Logan let me just explain this because I
don't think you get it
they're they're polite but that doesn't
mean they like you okay they may not
tell you that hey off you're an
but they definitely think it and
if you think I'm nitpicky
don't worry it gets worse this was my
life the Game Boy Color slogan goes to
the market to buy a Game Boy ah
why indeed why why what was the joke the
game seems to be malfunctioning
macho broken though much show broken no
much show broken no much much a broken
that can we
Neil deGrasse Tyson cringe me here we go
heck yeah bro Logan Paul clearly cares a
lot about his fans when they asked for a
signature as a good good old meme he
signatures as Toyota iQ you gotta
respect the clutch you gotta tell her
hilarious you got me I am the Pikachu
that's what he's saying right there with
this with this expression these are just
the scoffs that we see okay just I'm
just like imagining the ones that get
cuts out imagine that the ones that are
like oh that maybe that was a bit far
this is literally just his last three
videos before what happened what
happened watching them it all kind of
makes sense why he reacted with such
little empathy as he did he doesn't
really look at these people as people
he's treating them like something else I
get it people are tired of Logan Paul by
now I'm I'm clearly made mistakes too
I'm not allowed to criticize it I agree
100% with that sentiment I've always
said like I've argued with friends to
buy Logan Paul and people always bring
up like oh no Logan Paul he he's like
that old they're more mature brother
Logan it's not that bad compared to Jake
I'm from one sociopath to another okay
I'm a youtuber I know how they think
I don't watch Logan's videos I've seen
briefly of it and it's enough for me to
know his character and who he is he's
the kind of guy that plugs his merch
when he's friends dog died
I'm with you the whole though gangs with
you we got your back yeah it's gonna
feel weird it's gonna feel weird for the
next few days fortunately it is just a
fact of life and another fact of life is
literally right now you can get your
March on Logan Paul calm sighs yeah yeah
he's the kind of guy that fakes his own
murder in front of in front of little
kids as the epic meme
it's the kind of dude that invites his
fan to be in a song with him to boost
his ego and of course plug the merch
he's the kind of guy that mix out with
his brother's ex-girlfriend good mean
the kind of guy that tells people to
meet him outside of VidCon when clearly
told not to do that that's a danger for
everyone someone could seriously get
hurt don't do that
there's no joke I don't like Logan pole
I don't like his type of person he's
kind of person where I feel like if I
even tried to have a normal conversation
with it just wouldn't work he would
always just be like it seemed like I got
in a lot more for a lot less and I
like I said I don't think he should have
any sort of repercussion or whatever
from YouTube but at the same time
hashtag bring back scare PewDiePie
season 2 that's right nothing at least
bring back scare PewDiePie season 2 we
shot the whole damn thing alright it's
that it's waiting remember when plug in
your March used to be something kind of
frowned upon like okay all right you can
tell you can do it when you're launch it
maybe you can tell it but don't shove it
into people's faces okay I don't know
Matt oh god watch it tomato